Jim enjoys no saying I gotta let you go
you were just fired how many times but
listen that lowly family curse than
yours
well your brother's missing at home oh
that looks like it hurts
this kind of stuff don't happen to
normal folk I have full custody
I'm getting the lawyer with what money
I'm sorry good some sort of robbery to
do this Shawn motor speedway is the
biggest rate in the year I know how they
moved the money the only God knows about
blowing up lightbulb through Joe bang em
in car sir ring and yeah we got a plan
the kitchen well we're gonna do - oh
you're not a role model we need like a
computer with I know everything there is
to know about computers okay
all the Twitter's I know
across from secure location I'm Colin
own a phone like a real phone I met the
look let's all this time you thought I
was going to use this to get down a mile
yeah I kinda do man me too we are
dealing with science fear the system's
gone down they're gonna know what we
want them to know some are calling this
basically pipe I want everything on
Jimmy Logan right I saw what I saw
the purple 77 Alvarado I'm on my way to
church I don't have time for this step
out of the vehicle man I'm about get
naked little patience I said help bacon
see you late roll is Logan curse just
gossip
[Music]
you opens must be a simple matter is
labeled funny people say that what you
give me my arm please
it is this one
[Music]
you